Speaker 1: Let's go to everyone's favorite or
least favorite part of the week. Nobody is in
the middle on these. Hearing from the audience
segments, people either love it or they hate it
and they threaten to leave all the time. I want to
hear from some of the most important people to us,
the viewers, because otherwise I'm a guy in
a room with a microphone and some lights,
and it would be really sad. We take calls
on Fridays via discord. You can find the
discord at David Pacman dot com slash
discord. Let's start today with Mark
from San Antonio, Texas. Mark, welcome to
the program. What can I do for you today?
Speaker 2: Am I unmuted?
Speaker 1: You are unmuted
and coming through loud and clear, sir.
Speaker 2: Great. Thanks for taking my call again,
David. I'm I don't know if you saw yesterday,
but Kerry Lake again had her lawsuit tossed out.
And I'm just starting to think more and more that
unlike, you know, Marjorie Taylor GREENE and Mike
Pillow, I don't think she's a firm believer. I
think she's just nothing but a grift. And I wonder
if your take on it with with each subsequent, you
know, appearance she makes on media, it just seems
more and more like she's just a really polished
news person that's giving, you know, a polished
performance, however horrifying that might be.
Speaker 1: I tend to agree with you. And one of
the comments I made earlier this week was if she
had been unable to grift any money with this stuff
starting in November, she would have stopped by
now. The reason that it continues is people keep
donating. And now, even though it's it's being
called the last ditch that was now thrown out,
she's now saying she's going to try to get
it to the Supreme Court. And she even said
you can still keep donating. Even though I'm not
here asking for money, you can keep donating. I
believe that with Carrie Lake, it is a grift. I
don't think she believes any of it for a second.
She knows Katie Hobbs one, maybe she believes
some element of how the election was run was
unfair. But the idea that she's continuing to
fight to be made the governor, it's like that's
not how it works. It's not going to happen. I
agree with you that Carrie Lake is a grifter.
Speaker 2: Yeah, it's just it's it's performance
art at this point. And I think, you know,
if somebody on the left were willing to go that
far to create a performance, you know, a character
and then suddenly flip the script and, oh, by
the way, I'm progressive. I think, you know,
the right wing media would absolutely explode.
But here they've just platformed her for forever
when I'm sure she's probably somewhere in the
middle or moderately conservative. But this is,
you know, it's just insanity. It's performance.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I remember like, I don't want
to misspeak. But didn't she support Obama
at one point? Yes. Yeah, that's Kerry like
supported Obama. Yeah. Obama backing Arizona
news anchor became a MAGA darling. Yep. Well,
it is what it is. Listen, how is that San
Antonio Riverwalk? I've never been you know.
Speaker 2: It used to be just firmly
for tourists. And then, you know,
there was a bunch of money committed to extending
the river reach. And there's only like one last
section left. But you'll be able to go from
the museums all the way to the very tip,
you know, very southern tip of it, to the final
mission, the UNESCO's Mission Heritage sites. So,
you know, sure, the river walk downtown is just
nothing but restaurants and hotels. But once
you get outside of that, you can rent a bike
and right all the way to the to the Spanish
missions. And it's a good time. It's it's really.
Speaker 1: Pretty. I'm going to have to get down
there. Mark, I appreciate the call.
Speaker 2: All right.
Speaker 1: Thanks, David. All right.
There goes Mark from San Antonio,
Texas. Why don't we go next to Bentley
from Utah? Bentley, welcome to the program.
Speaker 2: Hello? Can you hear.
Speaker 1: Me? Yes, I can.
Speaker 2: All right, perfect. So I've just
been looking into some other countries like
Denmark lately, and I was wondering if you'd ever
consider moving to a country that is more like
socially democratic. You know.
Speaker 1: Listen, I would consider it.
The thing for me about, you know, Denmark would be
an easy one to go. I speak English and Spanish and
Denmark would be easy because everybody speaks
English in Denmark or most people do. I've been
there. It's a fantastic country. The cuisine was
great. The people were delightful. Expensive.
Expensive country, for sure. In really practical
terms, I'm not seriously considering moving other
than I would and I plan to, especially for my
daughter to get Spanish immersion. I do plan
to spend extended periods of time in Argentina,
and I've actually done so recently, like not not
with big fanfare, but there have been periods
where I've produced the show from Argentina,
but moving, you know, circumstances would have
to be very extenuating for me to move because the
reality is a bunch of my family is in the United
States. My job is in the United States. A lot of
my friends and, you know, this sort of thing. So
Denmark is a place. If I were looking to move,
Denmark would be a great place to move to.
I'm just not actively looking right now.
Speaker 2: Yeah, fair enough.
Thanks for taking my call.
Speaker 1: All right. Bentley from Utah, great to
hear from you. Very much. Appreciate that. Let's
go to is it Phineas? Let's go to Phineas from Is
it Kentucky? Something with a K? I'm not sure.
Phineas, please unmute yourself so we
can hear what your name is and where
you're going. Oh, Kansas. Phineas from Kansas.
Speaker 2: Yes, sorry. Phineas from Kansas. Hi,
David. Thanks for having me on.
I was calling to ask, in 2010,
the Supreme Court overturned Citizens United, and
if you look at voter participation before 2010,
it actually shows a decrease in voter
participation in volume and numbers.
And ever since then, we've seen a growth
in these numbers. I was just wondering if
you believe that as opposed to supporting a
party, the increase spending in elections has
merely just increased voter participation, which
could potentially back bite against Republicans
and have an advantage for Democrats?
Speaker 1: Well, hold on a second. You
said in 2010 the Supreme Court overturn Citizens
United. That's it. That's a the phrasing is is
relevant here because my understanding is.
Speaker 2: I'm sorry, in 2010. But yeah.
Speaker 1: The Supreme.
Speaker 2: Court.
Speaker 1: In 2010, the Supreme Court reversed an
earlier decision by a lower court, which upheld
that the First Amendment applies to campaign
finance laws and uncapped a lot of different
types of spending. We're on the same page on that,
right? Yes. Yeah. You're arguing that after that
happened, we've actually seen voter participation
increase, which isn't good for Republicans. So it
sounds like what you're saying is in some
underhanded way, might the Citizens United
decision of 2010 actually have been a bad thing
for Republicans? In my understanding correctly.
Speaker 2: That is correct.
Speaker 1: I think the difficulty of that argument
is that correlation is different than causation.
We would have to demonstrate that political
turnout increased because of that decision, and
I've not seen any evidence that that's the case.
Speaker 2: Okay. Well, I
appreciate your time. Thank you.
Speaker 1: All right, Phineas from Kansas,
a perfectly reasonable question, I must say.